volevo partire con queste quattro
immagini sono quattro screenshot presi
da internet che possono sembrarvi anche
banali comuni e anche totalmente privi
di significato
in realtà queste immagini rappresentano
l'inizio di una rivoluzione perché sono
i primi contenuti mai pubblicati nei
quattro social network che la maggior
parte di noi utilizza tutti i giorni o
comunque con molta frequenza da quel
momento in avanti la nostra società non
sarebbe più stata la stessa sarebbe
cambiata
basti pensare che oggi ci sono 3,5
miliardi di utenti attivi nei social
network solo su facebook sono più di 2
miliardi
più in generale il 98 per cento delle
persone che hanno un accesso a internet
nel mondo utilizzano anche i social
network e li utilizzano per diverso
tempo se si considera che il tempo medio
di utilizzo giornaliero per ciascun
utente di circa due ore e un quarto
quindi abbiamo capito come i social
network in breve tempo siano entrati
fortemente all'interno della nostra
società e l'abbiano definitivamente
possiamo dire trasformata in società
digitale o i society certo vi chiederete
ma perché stiamo parlando di questo in
un evento in cui si tratta di sicurezza
e per capirlo deve introdurre due
concetti
il primo è che questa rivoluzione social
ha portato enormi opportunità di
business opportunità di fare soldi che
sono state colte in maniera devo dire
veloce e molto efficace dalle aziende e
per aziende intendo tutto il panorama
degli operatori economici dalle enormi
multinazionali ai piccoli imprenditori
locali che quindi sono riusciti a
cogliere questa opportunità esattamente
per migliorare il proprio business per
fare soldi
il secondo concetto è che il mondo non è
popolato soltanto da operatori economici
legali e leciti ma ci sono anche quelli
illegali e sono molti ma sto parlando
chiaramente della criminalità
specialmente della criminalità
organizzata
qual è lo scopo della criminalità
scopo della crescita organizzata e fare
soldi esattamente come quello delle
imprese legittime e anche il mondo della
criminalità organizzata è costituito da
enormi multinazionali
pensiamo ad esempio alla ndrangheta o le
nostre grandi mafie ai nostri grandi
organizzazioni criminali che operano in
più stati offrono vari prodotti e vari
servizi a di piccoli imprenditori che
magari si associano tra loro per
compiere una specifica attività
bene anche loro sono riusciti a
sfruttare le opportunità di business
offerte dai social network facciamo
degli esempi la prima vi ho detto
opportunità di marketing quindi
l'opportunità di offrire prodotti e
servizi su larga scala ad una platea
enorme di potenziali clienti
lo fanno le aziende lo sappiamo le
nostri social sono pieni di pubblicità o
di offerte di prodotti bene lo fa anche
la criminalità organizzata con i propri
prodotti e i propri giudizi illeciti
probabilmente penserete che lo faccia di
nascosto che utilizzi i gruppi privati
che servono particolari regole di
accesso per avere appunto per riuscire a
vedere questi contenuti
in realtà no lo fa lo fa come le aziende
normali lo fa la luce del sole perché
deve massimizzare chiaramente la propria
visibilità tre potenziali clienti
se non ci credete guardate qui questa è
la trafficanti spa
i trafficanti esseri umani è da anni che
utilizzano i social per promuovere i
loro servizi ci sono centinaia e
centinaia di profili di pagine di post
di gruppi in cui vengono liberamente
offerti alla luce del sole servizi di
trasporto illecito posto nei quali
tendenzialmente ci sono informazioni sui
viaggi in partenze arrivi rotte seguite
prezzi dei vari pacchetti viaggio fino
addirittura ad arrivare a delle
promozioni come ad esempio sconti per
comitive ragazzi giovani o anziani
esattamente come le agenzie di viaggio
ma facciamo un altro esempio ecco voi la
farmaci senza ricetta spa sì perché
nella criminalità ha iniziato a vendere
utilizzando i social network prima lo
faceva con internet se lo fa con i siti
diciamo così adesso
molto con i social network ha iniziato a
vendere direttamente i consumatori
prodotti farmaceutici medicinali
medicinali
ovviamente per i quali non chiede la
ricetta medicinali che i consumatori non
vogliono o non possono acquistare in
farmacia
ad esempio come il caso delle sostanze
dopanti dei potenti antidolorifici degli
psicofarmaci o degli anoressizzanti o di
farmaci per le disfunzioni erettili
farmaci che quando va bene sono venduti
solamente in modo illegale e uso molte
virgolette perché sono molto pericolosi
perché assunti senza il controllo di un
medico ma quando va male e della
stragrande maggioranza dei casi sono
falsi false vuol dire che non funzionano
come dovrebbero che funzionano in modo
diverso che non funzionano del tutto che
contengono ingredienti tossici e quindi
sono molto dannosi per la salute e
possono essere anche letali ma
l'opportunità di vendere prodotti e
servizi non è l'unica sfruttata dalla
criminalità
l'abbiamo citato prima un'altra
opportunità sfruttata dalle aziende è
quella di cogliere i dati degli utenti
trasformare questi dati in informazioni
che sono molto utili per migliorare il
business lo sappiamo tutti si profilano
sanno tutto di noi sanno cosa ci piace e
chi siamo dove andiamo cosa vogliamo
fare gli serve per fare il loro business
ebbene anche la criminalità organizzata
è molto interessata a quei dati a quelle
informazioni ma se io sono un utente
incauto che nei social ha reso pubblici
una serie diciamo così grande di dati
miei personali non solo quei dati li può
analizzare ma li può anche rubare
insieme a cui dati può rubare la mia
identità non solo per utilizzarle in
ambienti virtuali e ci sono dei casi ma
per creare ad esempio documenti falsi
documenti falsi a mio nome
e cosa ci fa con questi documenti falsi
ad esempio va da un operatore telefonico
e attiva delle sim delle sim che poi
utilizzerà per scopi illeciti
oppure si fa dare un telefonino è uno
smartphone accredito e poi arriverà un
giorno in cui la compagnia telefonica
chiederà a me il pagamento per quel
telefonino
per quella sim e io dovrò spendere
risorse e tempo per dimostrare che io
non ero io
nel frattempo il nostro criminale
chiaramente senza allontanato col suo
telefonino con la sua sim e lascia me
tutti i problemi ma ancora un'altra
opportunità che viene sfruttata dalle
aziende è quella di avere un canale
diretto con gli utenti con il po con un
cliente con i potenziali clienti lo
sapete sono attivi dei veri diciamo così
innovativi ed efficaci strumenti di
costumer service attraverso quelle
aziende dialogo non rispondono a domande
e così via
anche la criminalità organizzata fa lo
stesso lo abbiamo visto il caso dei
farmaci profili che vendono farmaci
tendenzialmente rispondono agli utenti
ma la criminalità fa qualcosa di più non
contatta solo potenziali clienti o
clienti contatta anche potenziali
vittime e questo è il caso del sex
torsion ad esempio uno dei fenomeni
criminali più in crescita come
denunciato più volte da europol
nell'unione europea e in particolar modo
in italia negli ultimi anni vittime sono
soprattutto giovani e ragazze ma non
solo
cosa si intende con questo fenomeno il
caso tipico è questo io ho un criminale
che appartiene un'organizzazione che
contatta una giovane ragazza comincia a
chattare con questa nuova ragazza
comincia a intrattenere un rapporto di
fiducia
un rapporto di fiducia che via via
diventa rapporto di intimità e quando il
rapporto diventa intimi di intimità il
criminale chiede alla ragazza di avere
delle immagini immagini o video immagini
come chiaramente di natura sessuale
quando il criminale è in possesso di
questi di queste immagini di questi
video li usa come arma di ricatto dice
io pubblicherò queste immagini
pubblicherò questi video vi farò vedere
la tua famiglia li farò vedere ai tuoi
amici
a meno che tu non è qui le ipotesi sono
diverse al meno che tu non mi paghi
almeno che tu non mi mandi con
regolarità altre foto e altri video che
poi chiaramente il criminale il
criminale rivenderà in altri canali o
nei casi peggiori e ci sono stati molti
casi anche in italia a meno che tu non
ti prostituisca in una determinata zona
per un determinato tempo e di ha
chiaramente a me tutti gli introiti
abbiamo fatto solo una breve e veloce
carrellata in realtà di opportunità
zione sono veramente
tanti immaginatevi tutto quello che
fanno le aziende sui social lo fa anche
la criminalità organizzata e credo che
forse con questa breve carrellata vi ho
reso i social
insomma aver fatto un po di paura
relativamente ai social non sono degli
amici o solo degli amici come pensavamo
prima ma la visione deve essere positiva
e quello che ci dobbiamo chiedere come
facciamo ad arrivare ad una sicurezza
social
ci sono tanti attori che devono lavorare
prima di tutto agli utenti tutti noi
dobbiamo alzare la guardia dobbiamo
tenerla ancora più alta di quanto non
l'abbiamo adesso dobbiamo stare attenti
alle informazioni che rendiamo pubbliche
dobbiamo stare attenti a alle persone
con cui dialoghiamo all'interno dei
social network specialmente sono le
conosciamo anche nella vita reale
dobbiamo essere in grado di riconoscere
le minacce all'interno dei social e
quindi di evitare le trappole della
criminalità organizzata
chiaramente per fare questo l'utente
deve essere aiutato ed è con ricky
arriva il primo ruolo della ricerca
perché la ricerca deve continuare a
mantenere aggiornati i suoi studi in
materia in modo da essere sempre pronta
a fornire agli utenti le informazioni
utili per riconoscere queste minacce e
tanto sarà in grado di fare tanto più
sarà in grado di qom di raggiungere
questo obiettivo tanto più se la ricerca
di carattere multidisciplinare perché
perché se da un lato i criminologi gli
esperti di sicurezza informatica e così
via possono studiare e capire a fondo il
modo in cui criminali operano
dall'altro lato gli esperti di
comunicazione psicologia scienze
cognitive sapranno trovare le strade
migliori per comunicare agli utenti in
modo più efficace come evitare queste
minacce e questo approccio
multidisciplinare è esattamente quello
che utilizziamo noi qui a trento che
faremo sempre di più anche nel prossimo
futuro con l'istituto di scienza della
sicurezza
passa una domanda che si fanno spesso
quando parliamo di social network e
criminalità e questa domanda è ma se lo
fate voi ricercatori se vuoi ricercatori
trovate il criminale che vende farmaci
quello che offre servizi di viaggio
illegali quello che vende magari anche
altri tipi di prodotti illeciti perché
non lo fa anche la polizia perché non va
ad arrestare i responsabili e la
risposta in realtà è molto semplice
perché un conto è fare ricerca
un conto è svolgere delle indagini
diciamo che noi ricercatori siamo molto
più liberi gli investigatori non devono
semplicemente studiare il fenomeno
devono trovare prove prove che prove che
dopo devono utilizzare nei giudizi e
chiaramente è tutta un'altra cosa e gli
utenti dei social network i criminali
che usano i social network possono
essere ovunque nel mondo e quindi sono
necessarie indagini internazionali che
sono molto molto lunghe e molto
difficili da fare allo stesso tempo
immaginatevi l'enorme quantità di post
che ci sono nei social network e come è
possibile per una persona un poliziotto
soprattutto con le risorse star scarse
metterseli e trovare tutti questi
contenuti
servono strumenti servono strumenti di
analisi automatica che attualmente non
si sono e qui ritorna il ruolo della
ricerca e chiudiamo con l'ultimo ruolo
perché non mi sono dimenticato di loro
tutto quello di cui abbiamo parlato fino
adesso si svolge all'interno dei social
e quindi la domanda sorge spontanea
quale deve essere in tutto questo il
ruolo di suor dei soci i social network
stanno facendo un eccellente lavoro fino
ad oggi nel identificare in maniera
automatica e veloce rimuovere contenuti
illegali relativi a determinate attività
criminali pensate ad esempio la
pedopornografia al terrorismo non
troviamo nessun contenuto di
pedopornografia o di terrorismo
all'interno di social sono molto bravi
hanno degli algoritmi efficaci degli
analisti molto preparati per quanto
riguarda gli altri ambiti criminali
probabilmente c'è da lavorare ancora un
po
c'è da riuscire a sfruttare le
potenzialità dei social anche per
combattere questo tipo di minacce della
criminalità organizzata
quindi attraverso un approccio singh un
approccio sinergico di diversi attori
guidati anche magari dal ruolo guida
dell'università riusciremo effettiva
inter raggiungere un'adeguata sicurezza
sociale grazie mille
[Applauso]